Wow that's already a pretty there's your
dad there's a daddy Manson uncle Charlie
yeah Charlie passed away how sad are you
I am NOT sad that Charles Manson I'm
surprised I'm sure there's been a
Twitter outpouring of love and support
for you on this very tragic day
no he's 83 he's a really bad guy 83 is
not bad for prison life I gotta tell you
that's pretty old for bad guy locked up
for probably a long time and you think
he would have gotten the swastika tattoo
removed age well I'll say that because I
saw a recent photo and it was like
drooping like one of the corners just
started kind of started to melt away
looked like it was like a like a
uncolored rubik's cube falling down on
his nose right
I think it's they started as X's right
and then they later turned into
swastikas from what I remember no he
just was well I read helter skelter and
seventh grade and I think his whole
thing was they gave them X's on their
foreheads his followers to be like their
xed out of society and then later it
evolved into the Pleasant swastika okay
so I mean hey just a little I didn't
know if you knew that me and that you're
such a big thing that he was a big race
war guy so that's why I thought it was
always Watson right I think it started
as just X's the cultic but you're a
nutty thing to say what ensues will
raise your eyebrows to a whole new level
what happens upon being asked if he
himself is Jesus Christ
Henson explains that there are actually
many Jesus's all over the world okay it
is believed by some that so theory yeah
God appears in many forms but assessment
probably isn't what most people have in
mind number nine Charles Manson never
kills true one yeah Charles Manson was
convicted of you're right there's an X
on this guy so yeah started I see I know
these things
did you read helter skelter when you
were a gay teenager yeah okay I was goth
you know I love the dark stuff you got
to read helter skelter great great great
read real just light toilet read about
this thick about his about the whole the
Manson clan murders what started it all
yes really really neat reads degree
murder but he did not directly kill even
one of the victims for whom he went to
jail rather he ordered members of his
quote/unquote family to carry out the
tate-labianca murders
so when Manson told Heidi Schulman in
1987 that he quote never killed anyone
there's arguably some accuracy to his
word yeah however Manson's follow-up
statement makes about as much sense as
helter skelter
I don't need to kill anyone I think it
is Manson implying that he can kill
people using his own mind I think this
is the interview where he told her he
was overweight she had fat shame yeah
yeah not your type now is he the one
that did he get married you know how
some did he got married recently oh oh
that's no that's really much younger
woman yeah yeah was she hot she's she's
hot look a lot of people are hot for him
I mean in other words like compared to
him so yeah on the Charles Manson scale
yeah what do you think's going on there
and the women who choose a serial killer
or just murder as a life partner I mean
if you read helter skelter and you're
like I gotta meet this guy I gotta marry
him that's perfect yeah I don't know man
he's a world-class fucking psycho yeah
he's top of the line POS oh man such a
he's a drifter you know he's just a
worthless just well bag I'll tell you
what I remember of helter skelter so he
killed Sharon Tate and LaBianca other
celebrities who's of famous gorgeous
models oh that was
Lansky's wife well right right right
right that's right raped a teenager yeah
what a neat family anyway she was like
seven months pregnant with their baby
yeah and it's pretty horrific he was a
failed musician Manson was a failed
artist and he hated successful artists
and successful people called them pigs
said that they you know they're said
that it's a big setup show business and
Hollywood so he he took it out on tape
that yeah pretty horrific stuff and then
the guy that created full house bought
the Manson murders home that's real
crazy to buy the house of that happened
and be like just doing here build a
house here yeah yeah no no no I don't
think so no way that he can get into
other people's heads and influence them
to commit murder in any case it's
nothing short of bonkers I'm pretty good
yeah I think now it's here favorite of
the crazy killer I mean even though he
technically is not a killer but he yeah
you know is he my favorite like who's
your fav of the I don't have a thing
from jail homeless or your thug do you
like Ted Bundy no these are horrible
people Jean yeah but you lovely I don't
love them every night before I go to bed
I hear you watching the Unabomber Ted
Bundy Jeffrey Dahmer
I watched you know stories stories and
watch stories about you know bad people
sometimes yeah who's your favorite I
don't have a favorite there's no
favorite I just like watching stories
about crime okay there's no favorite
alright hey no no need to get so angry
alright I like Ted Bundy I thought he
was the handsomest of them all you
shouldn't like him he's I don't like it
I'm saying if I had to choose one that I
prefer to learn about he was a smart guy
he was married to um was he married yeah
he got married in court Bundy was yeah
how do you know so much I talked to this
girl last night about it cuz I there's a
bit I'd do a bit now about like the
wives of the Weinsteins in the car
piece of the world and then Manson came
up and she came up to me unfortunate but
he got married in court he did it
himself in court because he represented
himself he did represent himself yeah
yeah yeah his story's real fucked up and
yeah it's pretty bad yeah yeah he's he
was super deceptive and really
articulate for a lot of these guys are
really uneducated and you know Victor
after types like Manson
yeah but Bundy was drifter higher at
higher IQ yeah yeah
smart dude did he graduate law school he
may I was college yeah sure I don't
remember yeah he was fucked up in really
fucked up it's all about mommy these
guys get abused by their mommies and
then they end up hating all the women
yeah
[Music]